- Let's finish up with one last story,
I hope you're gonna love as much as I do.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
This year's March Madness
has already given us all
its usual narratives,
the unexpected defeats, mm-hmm,
narrow victories, the
Cinderella storyline,
but there's one moment from the sidelines
that you may have missed,
halfway through the Indiana
University St. Mary's
round one game.
The ball got jammed between the backboard
and the shot clock.
Players tried jumping
for it, no such luck.
They tried dislodging it
with a mop, it did not work.
So, check out how it did work.
- [Announcer] Well, maybe he's
gotta go on Verns shoulders.
(crowd jeering)
- [Announcer two] We
got Toss holding Fiffer,
that's, Kelly is not tall enough.
(crowd jeering)
- [Announcer] Major
issues here in Portland.
(crowd jeering)
- [Announcer two] Why don't
we get a new ball, why?
Why don't the cheerleaders
they're used to going up high?
Let's get a--
Yes!
Get the cheerleader up.
Get her up there.
(crowd cheering) This is how you do it.
(crowd cheering)
Give her the mop.
Now she's got it.
(crowd cheering)
Oh, what a play?
The cheerleader saves the day.
(crowd cheering)
- I love this story for so many reasons.
One being like, were there no
other basketballs to be found?
Like that's my favorite.
They were like, "It's the only ball
we could have possibly used."
We have those nimble cheerleaders
on the line now watching
on WTHR Indianapolis at 11:00 AM.
Say hi to Cassidy and Nathan.
(audience applauding)
What's up y'all?
So all these, all these big old dudes
out there try to get this ball.
So what were you thinking
when the ball got stuck?
Did you know you were gonna do that?
- I just remember thinking
like the crowd is booing.
Everyone is booing at the players
for not being able to get
it down and the refs but--
- Yeah, we were watching
and the players were jumping
up trying to grab it.
It was too high.
And then we had the referee get
on the chair and that clearly
wasn't working as well.
So now the crowd's booing even louder.
And so I hear our coach
from the sidelines tell us
that we need to put a stunt up.
We need to get somebody up in the air,
and Cass was ready to go.
So I grabbed her and we made it happen.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience applauding)
So--
Did you think you were gonna
be able to pull it up, Cassy?
'Cause even when you
went up the first time
before he lifted his arms, it
still looked like it was like,
"Oh, I'm gonna be too short for this."
- I was a little nervous,
but I had to get underneath
the bar, 'cause I was a little too tall,
surprisingly, and I had to
bend down and shift my weight
which can be a little hard to
hold, but we pulled it off.
- Yeah, you did.
(audience applauding)
Go ahead, go ahead.
- I was super nervous
because I thought that was
the worst possible moment
to drop a stunt.
If I was gonna drop one in
front of, you know, national TV.
- Cause everyone's watching.
- But we got it up.
Exactly.
And so we got the stunt up
and we got it all figured out
but unfortunately our team lost,
but it was like such a great
experience just to be there
with our program and with our school.
And it was just an awesome moment.
- Aaw, it was so cool.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you Cassy and Nathan.
I'm liking your post right now.
(crowd applauding)
(ring)
And that's not all our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a cheque
for a thousand dollars.
That's 500 bucks each.
How does that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
- It was worth the stunt.